takes as today's stress tests reveal the
core of our financial system is strong
major banks have capital ratios three
and a half times higher than before the
financial crisis we've worked closely
with the UK government other UK
authorities and European partners to
manage possible risks of disruption to
the financial system and most
fundamentally our institutional
framework is robust the bank has clear
objectives operational independence all
the necessary tools and the resolve to
deliver our monetary and financial
stability remix so consistent with those
dream it's the bank is publishing two
documents today the first is our latest
financial stability report which details
the important current risk to UK
financial stability and they run beyond
brexit but it also includes our latest
stress tests of major UK banks and
secondly our response to the House of
Commons Treasury committee's request for
analysis of how brexit will affect the
bank's ability to deliver our our
objectives specifically the TSE
requested that the bank focus on the
consequences of a potential economic
partnership with the EU and a No Deal no
transition brexit scenario
let me begin by stressing what these
analyses are and what they are not these
are scenarios not forecasts they
illustrate what could happen not
necessarily what's most likely to happen
building scenarios requires making
assumptions about the form of the new
relationship between the UK and the EU
the degree of preparedness across firms
in critical infrastructure and the
response of macro economic policies the
scenarios are calculated for the policy
relevant timelines for the bank that is
up to five years and as such they're not
assessments of the relative long-term
merits of different trading
relationships the scenario the scenarios
are however informative about the
relative economic impacts of various
economic relationships and the
transitions to them taken together the
scenarios highlight that the impact of
brexit will depend
the direction magnitude and speed of the
effect of reduced openness on the eve on
the UK economy the direction of the
effects of a reduction in openness is
clear lower supply capacity weaker
demand a lower exchange rate and higher
inflation the magnitude of these
economic impacts is modeled using
established empirical relationships and
it's disciplined by the bank suite of
macroeconomic models to ensure their
coherence and plausibility but the speed
of adjustment is less clear given the
lack of precedence of reduced openness
particularly amongst advanced economies
so the worst case scenarios assume that
adjustment 2d integration happens more
rapidly than it has over the past
decades to integration this assumption
is grounded by cross checks including
econometrics models case studies and
intelligence from the bank's agents
across the United Kingdom the MPC and
the FPC have reviewed the relevant
scenarios and they will use them as
inputs in their policy deliberations let
me turn to a few key observations
starting with the economic partnership
these scenarios reflect government
policy and are most relevant for the NPC
they show the sensitivities to key
elements of the new partnership yet to
be negotiated such as the extent of
customs and regulatory checks the degree
of non-tariff barriers to services trade
and the breadth of equivalents
determinations for financial services in
the five years under the partnership
scenarios GDP is between one and a
quarter percent and three and
three-quarters percent lower than it
would have been if the economy had
continued growing at its May 2016 trend
rate relative to the bank's most recent
forecast in November inflation is lower
in the near term in both scenarios given
the appreciation in sterling it rises as
the transition period ends due to the
fading apec's effects of that
appreciation and in the less close
partnership scenario as custom barriers
take effect from 20
21 a mechanical model of monetary policy
generates a gently rising path for Bank
rate over the scenario this should not
be taken as a prediction of the actual
path for Bank rates which will depend in
practice on the balance of effects of
demand supply in the exchange rate
turning to No Deal and no transition
brexit there are a range of possible
outcomes in the event of that consistent
but consistent with the FPC's remit a
remit to protect and enhance the
resilient resilience of the UK financial
system to major shocks the FPC has
focused on two variants labeled
disruptive and disorderly which are
underpinned by worst-case worst-case
assumptions in both scenarios tariffs
and other trade barriers are introduced
suddenly next spring the UK recognises
EU product standards but the EU does not
reciprocate in the more severe or
disorderly scenario the UK's border
infrastructure does not cope smoothly
with new customs requirements for some
time there's a pronounced increase in
the return investors demand for holding
sterling assets by the end of 2023 GDP
is more than 10 percent lower in the
disorderly scenario compared to that may
2016 trend
despite this sharp contraction in GDP
something that's bigger than the
happened during the financial crisis
unemployment rises to seven and a half
percent less than during the financial
crisis and that reflects the supply
driven nature of the downturn the sharp
fall in sterling alongside with the
imposition of tariffs pushes up the cost
of imports and overall CPI inflation
Peaks its 6.6 percent
in line with its remit the MPC does
what's necessary to achieve its
inflation target with bank rate rising
sharply to five and a half percent in
the disorderly scenario although again
I'll remind you that that is a
mechanical calculation the FPC has
assessed the resilience of the financial
system to these worst-case outcomes and
its key findings are
first based on comparison with the 2018
stress tests that were released today
the FPC judges that the UK banking
system is strong enough to continue to
serve UK households and businesses even
in the event of a disorderly brexit so
even after that unlikely event we
calculate the major UK banks will still
have capital ratios around three times
higher than they had before the
financial crisis and I'd ask you to
recall that the bank stress tests
released today is two and a half times
more severe than the brexit scenario
worst-case brexit scenario I just
described that is what being prepared
for all in venture ala T's requires
secondly major UK banks have ample
liquidity to withstand a major market
disruption they hold more than 1
trillion pounds of highly quality liquid
assets and can access an additional 300
billion pounds of liquidity through the
Bank of England's regular facilities
major UK banks can now withstand many
months without access to wholesale or
foreign exchange markets and thirdly the
FPC has worked with other authorities to
ensure most risks of disruption to
cross-border financial services have
been addressed and in this regard
two main actions remain further UK
legislation currently in train will need
to be passed for a fully and fully and
functioning legal and regulatory
framework for financial services to be
in place ahead of brexit and the
European Commission needs to provide
greater clarity to reduce disruption
risks and derivative markets following
their recent and welcome statements
finally the Bank of England with other
authorities has put extensive
contingency plans in place to support
institutional resilience and market
functioning during any period of
heightened uncertainty as we did around
the 2016 referendum
we're closely monitoring market
developments we can lend in all major
currencies and if required the fvc
stands ready to cut the counter cyclical
capital buffer if economic stresses were
to materialize now the bank's ability to
achieve its monetary and financial
stability objectives also depends on a
transit on both the transition and the
end state the level of preparedness of
businesses and infrastructure
infrastructure such as ports custom
systems and transportation operations
will be important determinants of how
well the economy adjusts to new trade
barriers evidence from surveys and other
UK authorities suggests that the country
is not yet fully prepared for a cliff
edge brexit survey suggests that less
than half of businesses have initiated
contingency plans for No Deal less than
a fifth of small businesses have done so
up to a quarter of a million traders
have never completed a customs
declaration eleven of twelve major
projects to replace key border systems
are at risk of not being delivered by
March 29th 2019 securing an
implementation period will minimize the
impacts on the UK economy the sober
objective assessment of the appropriate
length of that implementation period is
desirable to get brexit off to the right
start this implementation period should
be as long as necessary to prepare
properly for new trading relationships
but no longer turning to the end state
as you know the UK is home to the
world's leading international financial
centres at around 10 times GDP by asset
size the scale of activity of the UK
financial system and its complexity is
unmatched in other jurisdictions this
confers a special responsibility on the
bank to ensure that that system is
robust to a wide range of potential
domestic and global shocks
that's why irrespective of the
particular form of the UK's future
relationship at the EU and consistent
with its statutory responsibility the
Bank of England will remain committed to
the implementation of
Prudential standards in the UK this will
require maintaining a level of
resilience that's at least as great as
currently planned which Excel '[ __ ]
seeds that required by international
baseline standards and will also require
maintaining more generally the UK
authorities ability to manage UK
financial stability risks so to conclude
the Bank of England is ready for brexit
whatever form it takes the analysis
released today confirms that the core of
the UK financial system is resilient to
worst-case brexit scenarios we have
contingency plans in place to support
market functioning if necessary but to
be clear the bank being ready for brexit
is not sufficient to guarantee a
particular economic outcome this little
monetary policy can do to offset the
potentially significant hits to
productivity and supply the brexit could
entail our unwavering commitments to
price and financial stability will
support the necessary adjustment of that
real economy but the future potential of
this economy and its implications for
jobs real wages and wealth are not in
the gift of central bankers rather the
economic consequences of brexit over the
longer term will depend on the nature of
the UK's future trading relationship on
other government policies and ultimately
on the ingenuity and enterprise of the
British people and with that my
colleagues and I be pleased to take care
questions thanks ok as always you could
please give your name and also the
organization you represent and please
sticks just one question the first time
around I will start with Adam and then
son
from Parsons from Sky News governor that
the the bankers today presented a
picture of a No Deal
disorderly brexit that would lead to one
of the biggest economic slumps in the
recent history of this country so are
you part of project fear or do you
really think that we are looking at
economic catastrophe
no thanks big question Adam I would be
absolutely clear our job is not to hope
for the best but to prepare for the
worst and as I think we make clear in
the report is I hope I made clear in my
opening statement we have looked at a
potential No Deal no transition brexit
and made a series of worst-case
assumptions around that so for example
that port infrastructure is not ready
for example that the EU does not
recognize there's no grandfathering of
UK product standards and on their
detailed it quite extensively and also
that there's quite a sharp reaction in
financial markets the reason we do that
is to be prepared for all eventualities
it's to make sure that our banks have
more than enough and at three times what
they had even after that shock more than
three times than what they had going
into the financial crisis they have more
than enough capital for a disorderly
brexit to make sure that they have more
than enough liquidity and that as a
whole the way they're managing risks and
the protections that they have from
capital liquidity mean they can continue
to serve businesses and households
across the United Kingdom so we look at
that in order to be prepared for that
worst case scenario for a purpose and
the thing that I would underscore and
one of the things buried in an avalanche
of paper that came out today both the
reports but also the minutes that will
come out the record which will come out
in ten days from now will unredacted
Asians that the FPC and analyses the FPC
has been doing for the last couple of
years which is exactly looking at
exactly these types of scenarios and
making sure that we're getting the
financial system ready for something
which is an unlikely scenario and even
in that unlikely scenario we've taken it
to what we think is the worst-case
version of that unlikely scenario to
make sure that we've done our job we've
got the system ready and what we're
telling you if there's one thing you
take from the avalanche of paper and the
numbers and the discussion today is that
the core of the UK financial system is
ready for brexit whatever form it takes
from what comes through in your report
you say that the Bank of England is
ready the financial system is ready for
brexit but Britain is not ready for
brexit and there seems to be a lot in
your report that's saying part of the
severity of some of these outcomes is to
do with the unpreparedness of business
of households whatever for what's ahead
could you unpack that a little bit how
much is that to do with the severity of
some of these situations well again I'll
underscore particularly because this is
all relevant to No Deal no transition
and obviously we've looked at the
economic forms of economic partnership
of where there is a transition and there
is a smooth transition so in the case of
no transition and and again with our
worst case had to revise err on as you'd
expect us to be there are several
drivers of those outcomes it starts with
the frictions of of the trading system
because all of a sudden they're not just
tariffs in place but there are rules of
origin checks a series of customs
another check for which the system is
not yet prepared and so that adds on top
of it additional frictions and then we
have very and we've laid all this out
very clearly I think there are risk
premia that come into financial markets
at this
time in part relatedly because of the
scale of the economic shock and the
degree of unpreparedness and uncertainty
effects which hit business to take it
back to the core of your question which
is so what's actually happening on the
ground
it is our observation that has been for
some time that the number of business or
the proportion of businesses that have
contingency plans sort of initiated
contingency plans or who have activated
contingency plans remains a fraction of
businesses as a whole as you dig deeper
into that and you have conversations
with business and go at me in in several
cases it is very difficult for those
businesses to plan for border frictions
they can plan for tariffs they can plan
for a change in the price of selling
their goods but in terms of the
logistics of making that happen is very
difficult I heard example on on your
program this morning
you know of a very sophisticated
business which has that issue that's a
very common that's a very common
phenomena so let's flip it around the
situation is that the European Union the
United Kingdom certainly ignited Kingdom
government wants a transition period to
whatever form of brexit we're taking and
and certainly from what we have seen for
the economy as a whole it is advisable
to have that transition period that
implementation period and if I may eat
this this should be a objective
assessment of preparedness and the time
it will take to ensure that not just for
businesses and I go back to the point
and in some cases the logistical issues
you can't plan for these logistical you
can't plan around them so it goes first
and foremost to making sure that the
infrastructure is there and ready and
ready to go so that we can move
as seamlessly as possible to the new
relationship whatever form it takes
Joel Hills for my TV news are all of
your scenarios assume that Britain ends
up leaving the European Union in some
way shape or form what would happen to
your growth forecasts if Britain ended
up remaining well we weren't we were
asked by the Treasury Committee and I'm
sure we'll discuss it with them next
week to compare those scenarios that I
just went through the reference to so
quote-unquote the present position okay
which is a slightly ambiguous phrase and
we you could be from our perspective you
could interpret it in two ways the first
is the present position in other words
the current forecast that we have for
the economy which has an element of
brexit in it obviously because there has
been in effect as you know Joel on
business investment because of
uncertainty over brexit ISM the pound is
where it is because of brexit effects as
well so you can interpret it first as
that but you could also interpret it as
a scenario where we are part we remain
part of the European Union and the
cleanest the simplest approach to that
for us is to take the last forecast we
had prior to the referendum and as
you'll see in the documents is there is
a straight line called
May 2016 trend which is just an
extrapolation of the path that the
economy is on it's nothing more to be
absolutely clear than a mechanical
extrapolation of the trend rate of
growth of the that the economy was on
which is around 2% at that time and then
one and it's done throughout the
document you can compare scenarios and I
appreciate you using the word scenarios
not forecasts but these scenarios
whether it's No Deal or partnership
relative to either the forecast we just
came out with a Z MVC or that that
previous trend and you can make
your own assessment from that just so we
tell her that's a welcome if we come
back to you Joel on the second go if we
if we had time for second was been chief
from the independent governor you
mentioned this avalanche of documents
mentioned several times that there's no
historical precedent for a disorderly
Breck City there's nothing to guide us
from the history books I'm given that
what is the scientific basis for saying
as you have several times that this is
the worst case scenario that you've
painted here doesn't they dire as it is
doesn't that give us a sort of false
sense of precision about what we're
looking at here yeah well I don't know
I'll start a little pastor Ben obviously
you know one could take the most extreme
move in credit spreads the most extreme
move and uncertainty the the most
extreme moves in border frictions and
and add all those up we're pretty pretty
close to that
we're not precisely at that but we're
pretty close to that in terms of in
terms of what we've done what is one of
the most important things and I just
want to stress this though in thinking
about the dynamics here are how quickly
does the economy respond to the sharp
decrease in openness and it's a sharp
reduction in openness in the disorderly
scenario not just because of tariffs and
non-tariff barriers but because of the
logistical problems other factors with
that sharp reduction we have made an
assumption and it's grounded in some
case studies in some work but it is
we're very clear about this this is an
uncertainty we've made an assumption
that the adjustment is pulled for it in
other words the adjustment in the
economy is more rapid when you put up
barriers than the adjustment of the
economy than when you drop areas in
terms of a new trading agreement and we
and that adds a degree of difficulty
challenge
makes it worse the scenario worse and so
what I'd suggest we would suggest rather
is that you know we take we move to
these you know fairly sharp moves to
standard deviation moves for example an
uncertainty plus you have this dynamic
that's brought in it's it's it's
justified but it's we do it in order to
have a worst-case scenario but Ben do
you wanna yeah excuse me we do have a
lot of information by we I mean the
community of economists on the effect of
differing trading relationships where
volumes of trade end up and what those
do to productivity
you're right in general in terms of the
changes in those things that tended to
go in a positive direction
certainly in developed economies more or
less continually since the Second World
War and we've not had the reverse
experience so one important assumption
we make is that the magnitude of these
effects is the same in Reverse as it has
been on the way off as it were nothing I
was a reasonable assumption to have made
what is harder to judge and this is what
the government was talking about both in
the opening statement and just now is
the speed at which those effects come
through we think there are several good
reasons to imagine that they will come
through faster certainly and the most
disruptive cases there is one case study
we've used on the loss of access on the
same terms to the UK by New Zealand in
the mid-1970s it's about the only
concrete example we can find we think
there are independently good reasons for
that someone related to the state of
preparedness we were discussing earlier
why these effects will come through
faster certainly in the worst cases and
I would point you to the several pages
beginning at page 26 in the report as to
why we think that's the case so
to reiterate I don't think the scale of
the eventual numbers is is founded on as
little data as you suggest we've got
quite a lot for that the speed of the
adjustment were less sure about but we
think there a good reason to imagine
we'll be slightly faster D in on the D
integrating Messire than when you have
trade integration
England effectively endorsing government
policy and does that's a risky precedent
as some of your colleague former
colleagues in the Bank thing then you're
already starting to say that it could
set risky precedent for the independence
of the central bank well let's let's be
clear what's going on here the the Bank
of England has tremendous
responsibilities has tremendous powers
it is accountable to Parliament is
accountable to the people of the United
Kingdom it's accountable through
Parliament Parliament has demanded this
analysis right now this is the type of
analysis and as I referenced earlier we
have been doing this type of analysis in
order to do our jobs in order to deliver
financial stability monetary stability
and particularly on the former on
financial stability the type of work to
think about exactly what we've just been
talking about is what could go wrong
what could be really difficult where
could the financial system be caught out
and how well how can we get it prepared
so that the financial system is part of
the solution not part of the problem and
the good news is we're here today to
reinforce that and you have you know
pretty substantial evidence analysis and
in the end cold hard capital and
liquidity and if you'd like to hear Sam
would take up the rest of this press
conference by going through the numbers
more than happily do it in terms of the
assessment of a partnership arrangement
this is something that we also have to
do in order to develop and this these
are scenarios not forecasts and this is
gets to this one of the links between
the two which is we have to have a sense
of the potential implications of a
arrangement an arrangement that's
different after all than the arrangement
we have today with the European Union
and we have to have a sense of what UK
businesses and households think about
that arrangement which isn't necessarily
the same thing of what that arrangement
could
or will be and obviously what financial
markets think about it as well and all
of those map into ultimately demand
supply in the exchange rate and
therefore the path of monetary policy so
we have to do it and the second and
we've done it and if you have to do and
you've done it and Parliament demands it
and you're accountable to the people
United Kingdom through Parliament you
expose it and that's what's that's
there's nothing more here than that okay
just reminder if you mention which
organization you represent as well
please so Phil and then James yeah I
fell all drink it there at the times um
in your scenario planning you the worst
case in I use you suggest that interest
rates again rise to five and a half
percent as the economy crashes further
than it did in the financial crisis I
just wanted to establish how whether we
looking at theoretical extrapolations or
is this realistic that interest rates
will do the complete opposite to what
happened in the financial crisis and so
and what's your estimation of the
likelihood of the worst-case scenario
happening okay so the first thing is in
terms of the financial crisis I think
it's it's it's you know it's very well
structured questions so the complete
opposite of what happened in the
financial crisis well in many respects
this is the opposite of what happened in
the financial crisis because as you know
Phil the the financial crisis
principally at least initially for the
first few years was a demand shock it
was a big demand shock and actually when
you look back over the course of our
professional lifetimes and stretch
further back all the way into the 70s
that is effectively what the collective
we have been dealing with which are
demand shocks gradual changes in the
supply path of the economy some kind of
economy is doing a little better and
productivity a little more on labor
supply but gradual changes to the supply
side of the economy and addressing
shocks both positive and negative and
therefore monetary policy can be
calibrated to adjust demand accordingly
bring inflation to target or not if it's
miss calibrated obviously bring
inflation to target and support the
economy that way what's different about
this is it first and foremost is a
supply shock which then has demand
implications so it is a totally
different situation than people have
been living with and experiencing
certainly in advanced economies for the
last 3040 years we in that situation
that's why we've stressed the supply
demand and the exchange rate element of
of the frame in that situation we will
would be faced with a real challenge and
to be absolutely clear which is we know
the direction of the hit to supply there
will be a negative shock to supply
determining exactly how much of it is
coming in at what pace and how
persistent that is will be difficult and
it's part of what then was just talking
about in terms of do we think it will
come in more rapidly than historic
integration and if it is a scenario
which is unlikely to be absolutely clear
but we've got to prepare for the
unlikely one I'll come back to your
second part if it is a scenario where
there are logistical issues and other
frictions that are not frictions that
are part of the new trading relationship
but are just friction from adjusting to
the new training relationship we'll have
to make a determination about how much
of the hit to supply is temporary versus
persistent and that will also have a
bearing on the on the stance of policy
but all things equal in a sharp supply
shock the role of monetary policy is
more sharp supply shock with an exchange
rate adjustment which is driven by
future real incomes with
inflationary effect from tariffs which
we the last one we largely look through
the first one not necessarily it's
likely to be inflationary it'll be
important and in the end we have a remit
which is an inflation targeting remit we
can balance that remit to a certain
extent but we're not going to ignore it
last point in terms of likelihood you
know I the I think when one stacks up
worst case worst case worst case the
joint probability means that it's less
likely the possibility but it is a
possibility that we will have no deal
and no transition we have always thought
that it was a possibility a tail
possibility maybe the probability has
increased with time you tell me you're
probably closer to it but probabilities
increased with time but even when it was
just a small probability our job was to
get the system ready to deal with that
and you can't get it ready overnight we
think the system is ready to certainly
the core of the system is ready now from
the daily now and governor if your worst
case scenario came true and there was
Nate percent decrease in the size of the
economy would that make it the worst
would that make 2019 the worst year for
the British economy on record and given
that that is a clear possibility what
would your message what would your
message be to MPs as they debate two
resumes deal and and consider the
possibility of no deal on the on the
first no not the worst year in record
quarter I think we twenty when we went
back on the air Gold certainly peak
trough the drop was almost twenty
percent I think so yeah and that was the
last time that the bank gave advice to
the government I think it was to go back
on the gold which answers the second
part of your question which is no no
we're not our job is to get the system
ready for all possibilities it's a
serious job difficult job
we have moored enough to do that it is
absolutely not
to take one side or another on on on
these issues that is clearly the
responsibility of parliamentarians who
will weigh many factors in their
determination what that we all
ultimately serve the same people which
you know your readers the people of the
United Kingdom again what we really want
to get across today is there's lots of
issues that people I'm sure are thinking
about or concerned about or have
questions about the one area they
shouldn't have questions about as a
financial system and the purpose of what
we've released today the part that we've
released today the No Deal no transition
the disorderly scenario is to provide
that reassurance it's not supposed to
make people scared is supposed to
provide the reassurance that even if
this happened which is not likely the
system is more than ready for an arising
Telegraph and these forecasts which are
based on given scenarios and to what
extent do they reflect and the advice
you gave to cabinet I'm thinking
particularly the 30 percent fall in
house prices and the 48 percent falling
in commercial property prices and the
unemployment rate they seem very similar
to the figures that murder emerge from
that cabinet meeting and the barriers
that you mentioned to financial services
were they also raised at the cabinet
meeting and well
Bank of England independents in terms of
its its engagement with first off their
scenarios scenarios scenarios scenarios
you drift the yep you dropped the f-word
in there they're not okay
they're scenarios they're scenarios with
transparent assumptions established
economic relationships part of the
purpose of the scenarios as you can see
the sensitivities if you wanted to
change some of the assumptions you can
see the differences and that's why you
have
you have sways or paths around them
secondly you know look discussions of
cabinet or confidential log and you know
that's it that's full stop so and not
certainly not providing a commentary on
that what the responsibilities of again
this institution is to make sure we have
the system in place for what ever
happens whatever could happen in in any
direction and that's that's why these
that's why these were developed these
were developed I mean of course we
always refresh them but they were
developed a long time ago right I mean
we have been thinking about these issues
for a long time and we had used totally
transparent we had used language this
time last year those who came here for
this press conference we talked about
the stress test at the time incumbency
brexit scenarios in other words it and
you can see now transparently that our
stress test there's a chart and the
executive summary throughout the
document
which shows the capital drawdown in the
brexit scenario much bigger in the
stress test and then of course relative
to the size of capital it's it's very
manageable for the banks
that's what encompassing means so we had
done this before in different ways we've
we've updated it and
you know Parliament's demanded it and so
it's exposed that's that's it a German
Businessweek governor you said that you
need to provide greater clarity when it
comes to clearing and I think
outstanding cross-border contracts given
that you have this Joint Working Group
with the ECB can you tell us what's
happening there I mean why can't you
resolve these issues and we have four
months away from brexit how often does
this group meet how many people are
members of this group and why is it not
why I think they're not moving
satisfactory to your well I'll just say
at the top level and then I'll hand to
one of the members of this group john
calif just say the top level that it has
been a very constructive working group
grappling with the issues analytically
based sharing experiences and that i'll
say one other thing that a high level
which is that we welcome the progress
that that has been made but john i think
it's important that you so first on the
group the objective of the group is to
make sure that we all share the same
analysis we understand the risks and
where we can compare if you like the
analysis and the information you have on
the risks and the the group has done a
lot in that area on the specific issue
of clearing i mean this is a unclear
derivatives it's big issue 40 trillion
by notional value of pounds of contracts
and UK clearing houses will still be
there after the after the 29th of march
next year and clearly if the clearing
houses can't depend on the european
members meeting their obligations or
their boards can't know whether they're
going to be able to provide those
services they would then have to take
action which in itself could be
expensive and disruptive and that's why
as the governor said the statements by
the commission that have come
in the last few weeks our welcome
because they say the Commission
recognizes this risk and it will it will
grant temporary permission conditional
temporary permission to allow the
Clearinghouse to continue to operate
with the European Union clients at the
point that's made in the in the
checklist so that that's recognized but
for the clearinghouses missus first and
foremost an issue for their boards
they'll need to know the timing they'll
need to know what the conditions are
they'll need to know the scope what
products are covered so they can have
assurance if they don't need to take the
action they can take but I think the
European Commission's recognition the
temporary equivalents should be granted
I'm Alana Petrov from Yahoo Finance UK
in London I have a question for Mark
Carney now you got your UK passport this
month and I'm wondering if that makes
you feel more comfortable talking about
the risks surrounding brexit as you have
faced a lot of criticism for being
deeply negative about brexit so now that
you're a UK citizen do you feel more
comfortable thank you
I actually don't have my passport yet I
have my citizenship but I'm sure it's
sure it's in the mail the home office is
home office a little busy at the moment
the no look I interesting question I
feel as comfortable as I've ever done
talking about whether it's brexit or any
other issue facing the UK economy facing
the UK financial system you know our job
is to look at these issues assess what
they could mean for the financial system
for the economic outlook if they're
affecting either of our our objectives
price stability or financial stability
to take the appropriate
appropriate action you know look I will
say that during my time is a non British
citizen a great privilege to have this
role and I think a testament to this
country and its openness that it's not
about me but somewhat you know to bring
in somebody from from outside into a
role like this and that when I travel
around the country meet businesses meet
people I've always felt very welcome
very free to speak and represent
represent the banks thank you it's
Caroline Benham from the Financial Times
um governor you say with some certainty
that the UK financial system could
withstand the worst of all possible
brexit sand banks could continue lending
to the wider economy I'm just wondering
with how you can make such a short given
that your stress tests are testing
against the GD with GDP fall of 4.75%
and commercial property prices falling
at 40% when and you're disorderly
assumptions they fall by 8 percent and
48 percent respectively thank you yeah
so what we look at is so this is good
gets into the mechanics of the thing you
know if you can Sam can pick up on this
but what we look at is the interaction
between the level of rates the level of
unemployment and the change in
unemployment the change in the
underlying asset quality asset prices
also what happens to net income margins
as well and look at that in the round
you get a sense that'll pass to Sam but
I'll give you the page reference I mean
if you get a sense in terms of on page 9
of
the EU document it's also in the FS are
of the scale of losses including the
range of losses in the disorderly
scenario relative to an ACS and as I
hand off to Sam I'll just mention
something else which is inventory in the
in distress test the stress test has a
lot more than a UK recession in it that
hits banks but Sam yes I think Carolyn
that really is the key chart that shown
on page 23 of the financial stability
report which allows us to do a
cross-check against the normal stress
test we do and I think the simplest way
to express it is there in our normal
stress test the drawdown on capital for
the banks is five point four percent of
C t1 that's what we sometimes call the
triple whammy because you've got a UK
downturn a global downturn and a
misconduct at all at the same time you
come across into our our brexit shocks
of the analysis of how that would play
out in the disorderly snow that Marc's
been describing you can see that the UK
macro impact is pretty much the same it
comes from a slightly different set of
shocks but I think it's reassuring that
it's about the same as a UK macro part
of the annual test and then we've also
led in an element of the traded stress
assuming that there was a traded stress
around UK assets so when I triangulate
between us two I feel pretty confident
of the result
you have Richard Partington from The
Guardian governor you've explained why
you might need to raise interest rates
in a no deal scenario however I just
wanted to ask you know to what degree
would the recession in 2019 be as severe
if interest rates were cut to zero
would they be not as deep as that 8%
that you've ever focal and not forecast
estimated on your scenario they're just
to make a general point which is that
these are scenarios driven predominantly
not say overwhelmingly by what happens
to the supply capacity of the economy
that explained the difference across all
the sways mostly and maybe this is an
overstatement but monetary policy is
essentially a sideshow and it acts
mechanically to you know balance any
difference between demand and supply and
what and deviation is inflation from the
target really is not the main actor here
it has some role because the exchange
rate falls so far in the worst case
scenario at interest rates do have to go
up quite steeply to contain the
inflation that resolves but really the
the fact that that worst case scenario
is worse is because all the other things
we've talked been talking about that
affect the supply capacity of the
economy and that is really the story
throughout this report and that explains
the differences in all the scenarios
yeah so said another way I think my
colleague Michael Saunders said this the
other day at Treasury Committee lowering
interest rates isn't going to open a
port lowering interest rates is not
going to get a allow a bank in London to
continue to operate in the continent if
passport ian has been taken away and
it's that both of those examples are
examples of reduction
the supply capacity and the economy
needs to adjust to that
now if demand adjusts much more than
supply then it starts to becoming more
to become more interesting if you will
from a monetary or more conventional
maybe it's a better way to put it for
longer than that yeah you know we can't
get economic up but above that supply is
that over very long with monetary policy
concludes today's press conference thank
you very much for coming everybody